Một ngày 2,5 tảng 1 năm 2020, tông tin từ công an thành phố Đàn Nắng, đơn vị vui trị phá vụ trong tăng chứ,
một bản tình xà với vui mô lớn nhất từ trước đến nay trên địa bản thành phố.
Theo đó, khoảng 15.5 tảng 1 năm 2020, tộc công tá phòng cạnh rất đều trái phạm về mặt tui công an thành phố với hợp với công an phường cầm lệ đến hình kìm chắc là tại số bệ trăm 4.5 triệu chiếc.
Tại thế điểm kiểm tra lực lượng lượng trức năng phát hiện lối xí, sinh năm 2018, chú phần cầm lệ đang có hình vì phân triệu mà tui cẩn xà với số lượng gần tám kì lâu gắng.
Tại các phòng phía xongu nhà, phát hiện năng mấy mốt kể cần xà đăng được mưu trường tại đây, bố xí trong công zan kìn với đủ hệ thông xíu xám, tự nước.
Một dọc đấu tranh, xí khai nhận ngoài địa điểm chiến còn thưi và tổ chức trường cần xà tại cân nhà số 2,5 tảng tám, phần cầm lệ.
Tại vì thế này, phát hiện bố mấy kê cần xà với nhiều kỹ cự hát nhau đang được mưu trồng, công nhiều vật tư, phương tự dùng về trồng kê cần xà.
Đối hữu xí thường nhận, tự đầu thằng sau năm 2018 đã đảy sinh ý định trong cần xà để bản kế nơi.
Thông qua mạng sống hội telegram, gí đám 1 hạt sống, tổ chức sống, chức cây tuo hạt bản nhiều lượng mua bản tự xà với tổ số tiền xà xích 1,5 triệu đồng.
Cần khu tài lượng, chiến khu thu thập được, có quan kể rất đều xà công an thịt phố đàn nắng đã lập đi bản bắt người phạm tổ của tăng đối với đối hữu xí về hình viên 1 bản chè phép chức mà tui.
Đồng thời tiết tục đều xà 1 rộng, chiến xà các đựa tựa liên quan.